exactly said thank you you know the
saying Touched by an Angel well at the
Palms it's brunched by an Angel this is
the first ever Vegas show that will
allow guests to dine with the Departed
you probably have some questions so we
have the show's Creator and Emmy
award-winning producer here Shane Farley
along with one of the stars of the show
celebrity psychic medium Reginald Lewis
tell us what the spirit experience is
all about
wow let's start with you Shane you
created the show I did it's a lot right
what inspired you to do this well as a
talk show producer yeah I you know you'd
have celebrities and musicians and
politicians come to your show all the
time but the people that blew me away
were the people who had gifts and
talents that I couldn't explain and I
would watch the studio audience react
and I would see that there was something
really really special
when somebody comes in and they feel a
certain way and then they leave feeling
better then you want to do it all the
time so doing a show in Las Vegas with
psychic mediums it just made it made
perfect sense wow obviously there's so
many people that want to connect with
their loved ones Reginald can you just
explain what the experience is when you
walk into brunch how does it all work
well it's a very unique experience and
very magical experience and honestly you
truly have to be there to fill it
because it's the energy of the room I
mean not only do we have the band yeah
you know I mean amazing music when you
come in you have the brunch the great
food but then you have three meetings
exactly you know you can't you can't
miss that up so
um we have three mediums and the
connection that we have and the way that
we connect with people I think a lot of
people are actually very shocked when
they come in a good way because you
don't know what to expect but then at
the same time it's very special to see
those connections and to see the emotion
and people are really moved by it you
know it's a very emotional moving
experience for people but at the end of
the day it's good to see people uplifted
like he said earlier and see them just
feel like a weight has been lifted off
of them wow wow now is there something
that you could if any advice you could
give to people who are planning to come
to the show should they bring something
of a loved one they're wanting to
connect with how do any advice for
viewers or so you know they don't have
to bring anything bring your friends
okay bring your family bring your family
friends everyone that you know there
um because you know it's the energy of
the room the people that's in there that
just that really makes it very special
so I think it's almost like Christmas
when you're gather when your family it's
like that type of intimate connection
you know so when you have your friends
or have a family member there it's it's
a bonding experience it's a very
intimate experience wow wow now Shane
how can people join you guys they just
need to get tickets can they walk right
in how does it work yeah so you can get
tickets at palms.com or
brunchbyanangel.com and the great thing
is that right now like tickets start at
75 but if you get tickets now you can
get two for one okay or if you get like
the you get like the main seats that are
right in the front you'll get and they
cost a little bit more but uh you'll get
the bottomless mimosas for free and
let's let's be honest hello let's be
honest that's what we're here for right
and now many you know several mimosas
later they might be thinking they're
seeing angels in there too but you know
what Rocky the thing is it's like you go
see a psychic medium show and you sit in
it oftentimes in a theater of you know 3
000 people right so there's like almost
no chance to get red so at our show
brunch by an Angel it's like a really
strong shot because it's an intimate
room of being red and a hundred percent
shot of getting fed right see we like to
hear that yeah that's important the odds
are in your favor very Vegas of you all
well I'm so excited to see the show this
is such a unique experience JC I will
send it to you